[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى حلقه جديده من
مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
ازاله الكربون من الهواء صناعه ثوريه بدات
تفرض وجودها عالميا رغم ارتفاع التكاليف
وما الجدوى من المشروع السعودي لاكبر
مشروع لاحتجاز الكربون في العالم
[موسيقى]
قبل اسبوعين قامت شركه مايكروسوفت
بالاعلان عن اتفاق لشراء شهادات كاربون
على مدى العقد القادم لنحو 2.7 مليون طن
من الكربون المحتجز من محطات كهرباء تعمل
على حرق الكتل الحيويه تديرها الشركه
الدنماركيه للطاقه النظيفه اورستد والذي
سيتم ضخه في قاع بحر الشمال من قبل تحالف
يضم ثلاثه من اكبر شركات النفط الاوروبيه
اكوانور شل وتوتال انرجيس لم يتم الاعلان
عن قيمه الصفقه الا انها تاتي ضمن سلسله
من الاتفاقيات الاخيره المماثله في وقت
حاسم بالنسبه لقطاع ازاله الكربون سواء من
مصادر انبعاثه او مباشره من الهواء حيث ان
الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه المعنيه بتغير
المناخ كانت قد اكدت على ضروره الدور الذي
ستلعبه تقنيات ازاله الكربون في تحقيق
المستهدفات المناخيه
فقد توقعت شركه استشارات الطاقه ودمه كنزي
بانه لتحقيق هدف صافي صفر بحلول عام 2050
فان حجم قدرات ازاله الكربون يجب ان توازي
نحو 20% من الخفض المطلوب في الانبعاثات
اي نحو ثمانيه مليارات طن سنويا بحلول عام
2050 الى ذلك هناك عدد متزايد من
المستثمرين والشركات الناشئه يعول على
تقنيات ازاله الكربون مباشره من الهواء في
ضوء تحسن تلك التقنيات وانخفاض كلفتها
مؤخرا فعلى سبيل المثال تقوم شركه النفط
الامريكيه اوكسيدنتون بالتعاون مع شركه
كوربن انجينيرينج الكنديه بالتخطيط لبناء
ما قد يصبح اكبر محطه لازاله الكربون
مباشره من الهواء في العالم في ولايه
تكساس بقدره نصف مليون طن سنويا من ثاني
اكسيد الكربون بحلول عام 20 25
كلفت التقنيه المستخدمه في هذا المشروع لم
يكشف عنها بعد ولكن بحسب مصادر فانها قد
تتراوح ما بين 94 الى 232 دولار للطل عند
التشغيل وهذا ليس ببعيد جدا عن قيمه الرخص
المتداوله لاطلاق الكربون في الاتحاد
الاوروبي والتي تقف حاليا قرابه المئه
دولار للطن الا ان قطاع ازاله الكربون من
مصادر انبعاثاته او من الهواء مباشره لا
يزال في بدايته لكن القطاع متوقع له ان
يجد باستثمارات هذا العقد بحدود 150 مليار
دولار وان يتضاعف حجم قدرات ازاله الكربون
بحلول عام 2030 بنحو سبعه اضعاف ومع تنامي
تقنيات ازاله الكربون سواء مباشره من
مصدره او من الهواء في خضم السباق العالمي
مع الزمن ومع ارتفاع درجات حراره الارض
يبرز دور شركات النفط العملاقه في هذا
الاطار من خلال استخدام ميزانياتها الضخمه
وخبراتها الهندسيه والجيولوجيه
[موسيقى]
طرحت هذه الاسئله على الدكتور محمد ابو
زهره الرئيس الاقليمي لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا للمعهد العالمي لاحتجاز
الكربون وتخزينه لنتابع
اللي شاهدناه خلال السنوات الماضيه اشار
بشكل واضح الى تزايد هذا الاعتراف باهميه
هذه التكنولوجيا وهذا كان واضح من عدد
المشاريع التي تم اعلانها على مستوى
العالم وايضا بدات الحكومات والقطاعات
المختلفه ادراك اهميه هذه التكنولوجيا
فقامت بسن تشريعات داعمه بهدف تحفيز
القطاع الخاص للاستثمار في هذه المشاريع
فمثلا الاتحاد الاوروبي عندما اعلن عن
الخطه الاوروبيه الخضراء التي تهدف الى
صافي صفري عام 2050 احد الادوات الرئيسيه
في هذه الخطه هي استخدام تقنيات احتجاز
الكربون وتغسيله وكذلك الحال في كثير من
الدول حول العالم سواء في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او في منطقتنا العربيه
او في اسيا طيب هل واكب تشكل هذه القناعه
لدى صانع السياسات تطوير لسياسات الحكوميه
واللوائح التنظيميه التي تعزز الج دوى
الاستثماريه في تقنيات احتجاز الكربون
وتخزينه ما الذي تغير على هذا الصعيد
مؤخرا محمد وما هو المطلوب
نعم لقد تواكب هذا التغير في القناعات
بتطوير سياسات حكوميه جديده لوائح تنظيميه
تم الاعلان عنها لتشجيع القطاع الخاص
والقطاعات المختلفه للاستثمار في تقنيات
احتجاز الكربون وتخزينه من الامثله على
ذلك مثلا في الهيكل الصناعي نحو الاستدام
اللي تم اعتماده في الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعتمد بشكل رئيسي على الطاقه المتجدده
وايضا سياسات لتحفيز
الاستثمار في مجال الاحتجاز الكربون الصين
ايضا اعتمدت استراتيجيه الكربون الصافي
بحلول عام 2060 وايضا تعزز الاستثمار في
مجال احتجاز الكربون الولايات المتحده
كانت رائد بتمرير قانون الاستثمار
والوظائف في البنيه التحتيه اللي هو يدعم
قطاع احتجاز الكربون والانشطه المختلفه
مثل هيدروجين المرتبط باحتجاز الكربون
باكثر من 12 مليار دولار امريكي وهذا مبلغ
كبير سيقوم بتدعيم كثير من المشاريع لت
احدى جدوى اقتصاديه كندا ايضا قامت بانشاء
ائتمان ضريبه بقيمه التجاوز اثنين ونصف
مليار دولار كندي لمشاريع احتجاز الكربون
شاهدنا الاعلان عن خارطه الطريق في كثير
من الدول الاوروبيه وبريطانيا لتمويل
مشاريع متعدده في مجال احتجاز الكربون لكن
يجب ان نتفق انه بالرغم من هذا التطور
الحاصل الا انه ما زلنا نتطلب كثير من
الجهد والعمل لازم يكون عنا
سياسات متكامله لتحفيز الاستثمار من
القطاع الخاص وجلبهم للعمل مع الحكومات في
هذا المجال وايضا لتعزيز سياسات تبادل
خبرات بين الدول وعمل على مشاريع على
مستوى المناطق ليس فقط على مستوى الدول او
الصناعات المحدوده
في السابق كانت مشاريع احتجاز الكربون
وتخزينه تشمل كل سلسله القيمه لهذه
العمليه من احتجاز ومن ثم الضغط لثاني
اكسيد الكربون ومن ثم نقله ومن ثم تخزينه
لكن في السنوات القليله الاخيره بات هناك
توجه للمشاريح الجديده نحو استخدام بنيه
تحتيه مشتركه مع مشاريع اخرى لنقل وتخزين
الكربون المحتجز ما اسباب هذا التوجه نحو
جمع مشاريع احتجاز الكربون في مجمعات
مشتركه او ما يطلق عليها الهبز وهل هذه
النزعه المستقبليه هي النزعه التي سنشدها
فعلا
نعم ناصر في الحقيقه المشاريع السابقه
كانت تقوم على مشروع
منفصل في دوله او شركه تقوم بتطويره
وادارته لكن الان التوجه المستقبلي هو انه
يصير عنا او كلسترز تجمعات يكون فيها
صناعات مختلفه من ضمنها مشاريع احتجاز
الكربون وتخزينه
الفكره وراء هذه
انه اولا تحسين الجدول الاقتصاديه فلما
يكون عنا جمع مشاريع احتجاز الكربون في
مجمعات مشتركه سوف تستفيد من بنيه تحتيه
مشتركه لنقل الكربون وتخزينه وهذا سوف
يحسن من الجدول الاقتصاديه
لهذه المشاريع ايضا الفاعليه البيئيه بحيث
اذا صار عنا اي تاثير بيئي لهذه المشاريع
ممكن التعامل معها بشكل افضل لانها بتكون
محصوره في منطقه معينه من
الاضافات ايضا تسهيل التنظيم الحكومي لهذه
المشاريع فتق الحكومات بعمل سياسات لهذه
المجمعات المشتركه تستفيد من البنيه
المشتركه وعمليه التنظيم الحكومي والتفاعل
بكون معها افضل واسهل فهي بشكل رئيس
الدافع وراءها هو دافع اقتصادي اذا جدوى
اقتصاديه وعمليه التنظيم السياسات تكون
اسهل ايضا يجب ان نشير انه لما نعمل هاي
التجمعات او الهابس في مجال احتجاز
الكربون يمكن ايضا ربطها في الصناعات
مختلفه مثل هيدروجين الازرق او صناعات
الغاز الطبيعي اللي هي ايضا مرتبطه في
احتجاز الكربون فهذا هو التوجه القادم
وهذا سوف يعزز التعاون بين الدول فتصبح
المناطق هي مناطق
لاحتجاز الكربون مش فقط انها تكون مشاريع
مستقله او منفصله لوحدها سنتحدث اكثر عن
التعاون بين الدول في هذه المشاريع ولكن
لنبقى في القطاعات ما هي اليوم الصناعه
او القطاع الاكثر استخداما لتقنيات احتجاز
الكربون وما هو القطاع الذي يشهد او سيشهد
في رايك في المستقبل القريب النمو الاسرع
في تبني هذه التقنيات
تقنيه احتجاز الكربون كما نعلم يتم
تطبيقها او ممكن الاستفاده منها في المجال
الصناعات الثقيله في محطات توليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه وغيرها لتقليل الانبعاثات حسب
التقرير الحاله اللي تم نشره من قبل
المعهد عنا العام الماضي حاليا يوجد 35
محطه عامله على مستوى العالم تقريبا 14
محطه من هذه المحطات مرتبطه بتقنيات تنقيه
الغاز الطبيعي النيتشال
وايضا اربع محطات موجوده في الصناعات
الكيماويه بشكل رئيسي في صناعه الاسمده
فهذول القطاعين هم الان بشكل رئيسي يشهد
اكثر تطبيق هذا للسبب انه الجدول
الاقتصاديه لبناء الاحتجاز الكربون مرتبط
بهذه التقنيات هي ارخص بحكم انه تركيز
ثاني اكسيد الكربون مرتفع المشاريع اللي
تم الاعلان عنها بالفتره القادمه معظمها
يتجه في قطاع انتاج الكهرباء في محطات
توليد الطاقه مرتبط في انتاج الهيد الازرق
ومرتبط ايضا في الطاقه البيولوجيه فهذه
القطاعات اللي راح تشهد اكثر تطور في
المرحله المقبله ويوجد ايضا توجه لزياده
عدد مشاريع في الصناعات الكيميائيه وصناعه
الاسمنت والارتباط مع المحطات التصفيه
البتروليه طبعا نحن جميعنا سمعنا في
السابق عن تطبيقات تقنيات حجازي الكربون
في قطاعات مثل ما تفضلت الاسمنت الصلب
الكيماويات الاسمده ولكن هناك تطبيقات
جديده ناشئه في قطاعات توليد الطاقه
الحيويه تحديدا اضافه الى قطاع تحويل
النفايات الى طاقه لو تحدثنا اكثر عن تلك
التطبيقات ولربما نستعرض بشكل يعني هاي
ليفل جوانبها التقنيه
هلا احنا بشكل رئيسي نحتاج لتطبيق احتجاز
الكربون لتقليل الانبعاثات في الصناعات
المختلفه الان في عنا عمليه انتاج الطاقه
الحيويه اللي هي يتم فيها انتاج الكهرباء
عن طريق مثلا النفايات الزراعيه او
الصناعيه المخلفات العضويه او استخدام
البايوماس بشكل عام ميزت هذه الصناعات انه
انتاج الكهرباء يكون فيها خالي من
الانبعاثات او بنسميه
لانه ما بصدر انبعاثات جديده فلما نقوم
بالحاق تقنيه احتجاز الكربون مع التطبيقات
الكهرباء من الطاقه الحيويه ننتج ما يسمى
اللي هو
الانبعاثات السالبه يعني احنا نقوم بتقليل
الانبعاثات زياده عن ما يتم اصلا اخراجه
من عمليه توليد الكهرباء فهذا الانبعاثات
السالبه مهمه جدا لانه نحتاجها
السيطره على الارتفاع درجه الحراره حول
العالم وما نطلع عن درجه ونص الهدف
العالمي الموجود الان يمكن تطبيق نفس
الشيء تحويل النفايات الى طاقه الهدف من
تحويل النفايات الى طاقه اولا لتقليل
اثرها البيئي والاستفاده من هذه الفضلات
في انتاج الطاقه
لاستخدامها في مجالات مختلفه وهذا ممكن
تكون مخلفات صلبه او سائله او غازيه الان
بعد عمليه الاحتراق او التخمير اللي تتم
يمكن امتصاص الكربون وفصله عن طريق تقنيات
احتجاز الكربون فهذا ايضا بعطينا اللي هو
الانبعاثات سالبه للكربون ويقلل من تاثير
هذه العمليات تريد الكهرباء على المناخ
بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
نتوقف الان مع فاصل قصير نتابع بعده في
مستقبل الطاقه
ما الحل لارتفاع تكلفه ازاله الكربون
مباشره من الهواء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مستقبل الطاقه
مشاريع احتجاز الكاربون وتخزينه تفرض
نفسها كخيار استراتيجي لدول المنطقه لكن
يبقى السؤال عن الجدول الاقتصاديه لهذا
النوع من المشاريع عالميا في حال لم يتم
تشريع سعر للكربون ناقشت هذا الامر مع
الدكتور محمد ابو زهره من المعهد العالمي
لاحتجاز الكربون وتخزينه لكن ايضا سالته
قبل ذلك عن التقدم الذي حققته تقنيه ازاله
الكربون من الهواء مباشره
تقنيه ازاله الكربون مباشره من الهواء
وتخزين اللي هي او داك تقوم على ازاله
ثاني اكسيد الكربون مباشره من الهواء فهذا
بعطيها امكانيه انه ممكن يتم ازاله
الكربون من اي مكان حول العالم مهما كان
حجمه فبتكون من مصادر صغيره ومنتشره فما
بنحتاج انه نكون مرتبطين في مصدر انبعاثات
الكربون كما هو الحال في محطات توليد
الكهرباء او في الصناعات الان ميزه هذه
التقنيه اولا اننا نحتاجها للوصول الى
الصافي الصفري يعني احنا اذا قمنا بتطبيق
كل
الديكربونيزيشن تولز اللي راح نستخدمها
ومن ضمنها احتجاز الكربون راح يضل عنا او
كميه انبعاثات يجب ازالتها من الهواء
مباشره وهنا ياتي اهميه الداك في تحقيق
الحياد الصفري الكربوني وتحقيق الانبعاثات
السالبه الان ميزتها انه لماذا
الاستقبال عليها في الفتره الاخيره اولا
لحاجتنا لها وهذا ما تم تاكيده في الاي بي
سي سي روبورت وغيرها ايضا عدم ارتباطها
بشكل مباشر في الوقود الاحفوري فهي ممكن
تكون حل لكثير من الصناعات او الهارت
وما تكون بشكل رئيسي مرتبطه بالوقود
الاحفوري تكلفتها ما زالت مرتفعه احنا
بنتحدث عن تكنولوجيا ممكن تكون تكلفتها
اكثر من 400 دولار لازاله طن واحد من ثاني
اكسيد الكربون لكن التكنولوجيا يتم الان
تطبيقها في محطات مختلفه وفي تطوير على
التكنولوجيا لتخفيض اسعارها وكلفتها
مستقبلا ويوجد اقبال عليها بحيث انها تكون
هي وسيله للكاربون اوف ستريم ماركت وهذا
ايضا يعزز من دورها المستقبلي
ليبقى هناك سؤال مهم جدا محمد حول الجدول
الاقتصاديه لمشاريع احتجاز الكربون
وتخزينه بشكل عام في حال لم يتم تشريع سعر
للكربون الى اي مدى سيكون تسعير الكربون
امر حاسم في نمو صناعه احتجاز الكربون
اعتقد انه هذا امر حاسم وضروري جدا يعني
احنا في مرحله معينه يجب ان نصل انه يوجد
عنا سعر كربوني يتم تداوله بطرق مختلفه
وتلتزم فيه الدول والصناعات المختلفه فيجب
وضع انظمه تسعير كربون بحيث انها تحفز
الشركات على الاستثمار في هذه التقنيات
وهذه الانظمه يعني ممكن تكون على شكل
ضريبه على انبعاثات الكربون كما هو الحال
مثلا في اوروبا او عن طريق انظمه تداول
هذه الانبعاثات سواء كانت طوعيه او
اجباريه في المستقبل وممكن عن طريق وضع
سعر كربوني ويتم اخذه او اعطائه
ائتمان ضريبه كما هو الحال في شمال امريكا
يوجد حاليا العديد من الانظمه موجوده حول
العالم من اجل تسعير الكربون وتداوله كما
هو الحال في النظام التداول في الاتحاد
الاوروبي او نظام التجاره بالانبعاثات في
كاليفورنيا او
المختلفه بورصات الكربون حول العالم سواء
في الصين او استراليا او ما يتم الان
العمل على اطلاقه في المنطقه العربيه فهذا
ستكون حجر اساسي وركن اساسي
لتطوير تطبيق تكنولوجي احتجاز الكربون
وبدون ما يكون عنا سعر واضح او تسعير او
او تقنيه لتداول هذا الكربون ما راح نقدر
انه ندفع
القطاع الخاص للاستثمار في هذه
التكنولوجيا دعنا في نهايه اللقاء محمد
نتحدث عن منطقتنا اين تقع منطقتنا العربيه
في لائحه دول العالم على صعيد مشاريع
احتجاز الكربون وتخزينه ضمن
تقييماتكم وتقريركم السنوي في المعهد وما
هي القدرات التي تتمتع بها منطقتنا
القابله لتطوير يعني سلسله قيمه متكامله
للكربون
المنطقه العربيه ومنطقه الخليج العربي
بشكل خاص فيها حاليا ثلاث مشاريع عامله
مجمل احتجاز الكربون في هذه الثلاث مشاري
يعادل تقريبا ثمانيه الى 10% من مجمل
يحتاج احتجاز الكربون حاليا حول العالم
قامت عديد من الدول باطلاق مبادرات واعلان
مشاريع قادمه من اهمها مهتم اعلانه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه عن تاسيس اكبر
مركز احتجاز الكربون في منطقه الجبيل
الصناعيه في شرق المملكه وهذا هو اول هاب
وكلاستر لاحتجاز الكربون في المنطقه ومن
اكبر هذه الهابس حول العالم وهذا سيكون
لدور كبير في تعزيز ودفع التكنولوجيا في
المستقبل ايضا في منطقه الامارات شركه
ابوظبي الوطنيه اعلنت عن المرحله الثانيه
والثالثه لمشاريع احتجاز الكربون
ارامكو السعوديه اعلنت في خطتها
الاستراتيجيه للاستدامه عن هدف في 2030
يجب الوصول له من حيث انه 11 مليون طن من
ثاني اكسيد الكربون يتم احتجازه فيوجد عنا
العديد من المبادرات والمشاريع العامله
السياسات ايضا بدات تدفع باتجاه تعزيز
قيمه الكربون فمثلا الكونسبت لقيمه
متكامله للكربون ايكونومي هذا موضوع مهم
جدا في المنطقه الارتباطه بين تقنيه
احتجاز الكربون تقنيات انتاج الغاز
والبترول في المنطقه والصناعات المختلفه
الان المنطقه العربيه فيها ميزات مختلفه
اولا يوجد عنا كثير من الشركات العامله في
مجال الطاقه والنفط والغاز وهذا سوفكنها
يكون لها دور اساسي في تطبيق واداره
مشاريع احتجاز الكربون في المستقبل فعنا
احنا
الخبرات المطلوبه في هذا المجال ايضا اذا
بنتطلع على تخزين الكربون المنطقه العربيه
الجيولوجيا الموجوده فيها في منطقه الخليج
العربي ملائمه جدا لتخزين الكربون لفترات
طويله وممكن حتى تكون هي
يعني فرصه لتخزين الكربون من دول اخرى يتم
نقل ثاني اكسيد الكربون منها الى هذه
المنطقه فاحنا نشهد بشكل عام زياده وعي في
المنطقه الاهميه محاربه التغير المناخي
للحفاظ على البيئه ومن ضمنها ايضا زياده
وعي باهميه مشاريع احتجاز الكربون وتخزينه
والدول المختلفه يعني في المنطقه تقوم
بدعم هذه المشاريع ووضعها ضمن سياساتها
لتحقيق صافي صفري لعام 2050
[موسيقى]
لهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه من
مستقبل الطاقه دائما تابعونا على تويتر
تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه يمكنك ايضا
الاستماع الى حلقاتنا على العربيه بودكاست
وايضا مشاهده حلقات البرنامج كامله على
موقعنا على الانترنت العربيه.
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات